desde hace más de mil años el monte San
Michelle vigila con orgullo la entrada
del estuario de kunon construido sobre
una isla mareal en la costa normanda
este lugar declarado patrimonio de la
humanidad por la UNESCO ha tenido
durante mucho tiempo un fuerte
significado religioso reconocido como
lugar de peregrinación para quienes
viajan desde Gran Bretaña a Santiago de
Compostela es un acto de valentía que ha
sobrevivido a los años y a los siglos y
nos preguntamos cómo lo hicieron es un
reto arquitectónico solo piensen como
construyeron esto en arenas movedizas
sin toda la maquinaria y toda la todas
las herramientas que tenemos hoy es
asombroso
Según la leyenda en el año 708 el
Arcángel Miguel ordenó a un Obispo local
erigir un santuario en La Roca los
constructores utilizaron granito una
roca más resistente que la caliza local
las piedras se encontraron a unos 30
kilómetros de aquí en las islas
se extraían y se extraían en barcos de
fondo plano en función de las mareas
el monte San Michelle ha evolucionado
significativamente a lo largo de los
siglos
[Música]
esta rampa aún visible hoy en día se
utilizaba antiguamente para transportar
piedras hasta la cima de la Colina con
la ayuda de esta rueda de madera
esta rueda de accionamiento se parece
exactamente a la que se utilizaba hace
1000 años para levantar las rocas que
las barcas llevaban al fondo de la
Colina los hombres caminaban sobre la
rueda que a su vez empujaba un carro de
carga por la rampa este carro de carga
podría llevar hasta dos toneladas de
piedras
al descender a las profundidades de la
abadía esta capilla Revela la
complejidad de la estructura
en total se construyeron cuatro criptas
para sostener este edificio
estas criptas ayudaron a sostener el
edificio sin estas criptas no existiría
esta gran iglesia románica sobre
nosotros construidas hace unos mil años
[Música]
el monte San Michel ha superado la
prueba del tiempo Sobreviviendo a lo
largo de los siglos una longevidad que
la ha hecho famosa en todo el mundo y
que los monjes que viven aquí se
encargan de que siga siendo así
ninguna creación humana es intemporal o
eterna
todas las creaciones humanas en algún
momento terminan por colapsar y
reconstruirse
mil años después esta maravilla
arquitectónica sigue atrayendo a
turistas de todo el mundo con casi 3
millones de visitantes al año
[Música]